hi guys I'm Eric Voss and this is a
breakdown of the walking dead season 7
episode 5 go-getters and this episode
finally brought us home to Jesus along
with the hilltop and Craig Jeffrey
Gervais Gerber I think that's it Gerber
you really got to start putting names to
faces Gerber there was a lot of cool
stuff I noticed in this episode
specifically some details that set up
some really interesting story arcs from
the comics and I'm gonna break it all
down for you so let's get started with
the opening images so the first shot of
the episode is this close-up of Maggie's
eyes now I wouldn't just single out any
generic shot of someone's eyes as
particularly meaningful it is after all
a pretty common trope these days lost
did it in pretty much every episode but
it's interesting here because it
connects back to the first shot of the
season premiere showing us Rick's eyes
remember that was meant to establish
Rick in a state of defiance which negan
would shatter into submission by the end
of the episode and I think it's actually
that closing shot of Rick's eyes moments
after negan's violent introduction that
this shot of Maggie is meant to compared
to now it's pretty clear that the show
is setting up Maggie to be a leader just
like Rick is but even though she's in
this enormous physical pain and
emotional pain she just lost her husband
Maggie state of mind is unlike Rick one
of strength that's why in the immediate
next shot we see these blue flowers and
later Jesus tells Maggie that the color
blue evokes calm and strength now let's
talk about this doctor dr. Carson we met
him at the hilltop last season and the
show hasn't really underlined this but
this guy is the brother of the other dr.
Carson we've met who's the Savior's
doctor at the sanctuary that was dr.
Emmett Carson and this is dr. Harlan
Carson and I love the idea of these two
medic brothers being on different sides
of the conflict between the Savior's in
the group's the oppressed kind of like
brothers who fought on opposite sides of
the American Civil War but also notice
how this dr. Carson reports that
Maggie's baby is still healthy whereas
the other dr. Carson was reporting to
Sherri that she wasn't getting pregnant
it's a small detail but I think it's
meant to depict the hilltop as a fertile
ground where life grows both vegetables
from the soil and little baby veggies
that contrasts the sanctuary which is a
more sterile place where things go to
die in life cannot take root and we see
this idea take on another form as we
move on outside to Glen and Abraham's
graves we get more
floral imagery with these sunflowers and
this reaffirms the idea of the hilltop
being a place of fertility in life
because sunflowers always face the Sun
they rotate throughout the day and
throughout the time of the year and they
are symbols of the vitality that
sunlight brings so even in this morbid
gravesite we're still meant to see the
hilltop as a place where life springs
anew now this is actually the first time
we've got to see anyone fully grieve
Glen and Abraham and there's a few
things I like about the scene one it's
cool how they use these physical tokens
as a way to manifest their grief so like
there's Glen's pocket watch given to him
by Maggie's father Hershel and Abraham's
cigar which Sasha says she found in his
pocket that watch has been associated
with Glenn for a while now it was on
Steven Yeun tidal slide when he was
still on the show and I like how it now
represents the wisdom of one generation
passing down to the other from Herschel
to Glen and in later this episode Glenn
and Maggie to Enid meanwhile Abraham's
cigar represents the reckless hedonistic
spirit that Abraham lived his life by
and the same goes for the necklace that
Rosita gave Abraham which Jesus returns
to Sasha later it's a symbol of the hot
passionate light that he was trying to
move on from huh look at that I've gone
a few minutes without making any kind of
religious analogy so let's fix that so I
like how even in death this show extends
the recurring Christ's metaphor with
Glen so in the Bible Jesus's burial and
resurrection were witnessed by Mary
Magdalene another woman who's called the
other Mary probably Mary the mother of
James and in some versions a third woman
and I think those three women could
correspond to the three women we see
morning Glenn and Abraham in this
episode now there's some historical
confusion over who was there and what
their names were and I think that
confusion is actually echoed in
Gregory's idiotic praying parts here
Colleen Maggie Marcia and mistaken Sasha
as just a regular Hilltopper now that
could also just be part of Gregory's
sexist worldview and power manipulation
like intentionally calling people by the
wrong name to kind of catch them off
guard and quick aside here I want to
point out the framing of Gregory in
front of the wheels of the tractor this
shot of course is meant to establish
that the hilltop has this massive
tractor which will obviously come in
handy later but also to foreshadow that
Gregory's rule over the hilltop is about
to be mowed down now that biblical
reference that I mentioned does not mean
that I think Glenn will be rising from
the dead again
I really don't need to see that happen
wait don't did you to God not cool but
it is interesting that this moment is
followed by the long-awaited return of
another Jesus he is risen and not only
does he kick some serious ass this
episode he helps Maggie and Sasha
understand an important concept he tells
them that he uses green flowers on the
graves because green is the color of
reliefs and then later he explains why
the Hilltoppers burned their dead the
idea was just to keep going why do you
have to remember us
so those physical tokens the watch the
cigar the necklace they help them
remember their loved ones but they also
weighed them down with grief so they
need to be released but let's move on to
Alexandria and we get this shot of
Carl's darks completely missing the
dartboard veering to the left I like
this detail as a reminder that Carl's
vision is skewed by missing his right
eye which distorts his focus and sense
of direction but I also like how this
reveals his character and connects him
to Michonne so Carl is missing but he's
still chucking those darts hard enough
to lodge them into the wall rather than
like bounce off and remember last
episode Michonne also struggled with
target practice angrily firing round
after round at that Walker in the field
I think these parallel moments are meant
to show that Carl and Michonne are both
filled with untapped anger over not
retaliating against Megan but that anger
has also clouded their vision over
what's the best direction to focus that
energy leaving them both to take matters
into their own hands and maybe not the
smartest way now this episode is titled
go-getters and on the surface that seems
like a description that would fit people
like Rick Arryn and maybe Gregory who
have accepted their subservient fates
people who literally go get things for
the Savior's on the other hand when you
call someone a go-getter you're really
saying there's someone who takes
initiative who goes after what they want
without waiting for permission and
really that more closely describes the
real heroes of this episode despite how
reckless they might be people like Carl
Eamonn Maggie Sasha and Jesus and that
go-getter sense of drive without the
sharpest vision comes up again when Carl
saves Enid although I don't really know
if she needed saving by running down
this Walker with a car and wrecking it
in the process I like how this pulse a
drive slowly someone's not keeping their
one eye on the road now honestly before
I saw it was Carl behind the driver's
seat I thought this might be a new
character and part of me was hoping it
would be like Walter White since we saw
him do the same thing to save Jesse in
Breaking Bad
and you know after we saw that Easter
egg with the blue meth in Murrells drug
bag this wouldn't be the first Walking
Dead Breaking Bad crossover in the AMC
extended universe and before I move on I
mentioned how in the Bible some versions
say a third person witnessed Jesus's
burial and I think in this loose
allusion that third woman is Enid and
check out what we see at the start of
this scene when the camera lines up a
pole in front of this horizontal beam I
don't know that looks a lot like a
crucifixion grass or maybe I'm just
seeing crosses everywhere again not
trying to convert anyone hail Hydra
moving on now this midseason sequence
with the hilltop under attack might be
my favorite action scene from this
season so far and one of the things that
makes it so great is the music blaring
from this car that's been sealed shut by
the Savior's as a trap to lure in
Walker's
this song is called Finlandia opus
number 26 and it's by the finnish
composer Jean Sibelius he wrote it in
1899 as a covert protest by the people
of Finland against the oppressive
Russian Empire now obviously I don't
think the savior's knew this history
because it makes a really fitting score
for that moment of Maggie Sasha and
Jesus leading the hilltop to fight off
and attack by the oppressive Empire that
rules over them but it also makes a lot
of sense that the saviors would pick
this song because it was used
prominently in the movie die hard - we
know that they watch a bunch of old
movies and TV shows of the sanctuary so
you can imagine these dudes like
watching die r2 and picking the song and
lighting fires all over the hilltop as a
way to say you Calle a mother first
but it's Maggie who channels her inner
John McClane here backing this tractor
over the car and crushing a ton of
Walker's in the process it's a kind of
destructive yet practical stunt McClane
would do to quickly solve a problem so
this along with Jesus and Sasha taking
down the walkers and from the flames of
the whole moon this is the biggest full
sensory spectacle we've seen on The
Walking Dead
since the defending of Alexandria last
season I'll come back to Carl and eat it
in a bit but for now let's move on to
Simon sitting down with Gregory
now check out this painting this also
showed up in episode 11 of last season
this is a portrait of Emperor Charles
2/5 on horseback by Anthony Van Dyck now
historically Charles 2/5 was one of the
most powerful rulers in European history
he ruled over the Holy Roman Empire
which covered Spain German territories
in Austria as well as Rome and southern
Italy Charles a bit constantly waged war
to keep his territories tightly under
his rule by the way in real life this is
a priceless 16:20 painting that hangs in
the Uffizi gallery in Florence Italy so
how the hell did it end up in rural
Virginia I think maybe it could have
been on exhibit in the National Gallery
and nearby Washington DC then maybe
someone looted it or you know maybe the
zombie apocalypse is no excuse to cancel
some high fancy art deals nevermind the
zombies I've been 20 million on the
painting though anyway Gregory hanging
this in his office is a reflection of
his overinflated ego but Simon
interprets it another way that's
management by
Simon is impressed by the show of power
by Charles abit here a sense of awe that
he leaves his people with as he parades
around the battlefield
now Simon explains to Gregory that that
was the purpose of the fire and the
music to project their power in the
midst of this dangerous world
now Simon was really fun to watch this
episode his behavior and expressions are
super over the top kind of like negan
light so it makes sense that he would
admire this image of Charles 1/5 because
he has been played an ego of his own
which is precisely why when he sits down
on the desk his face is framed by
another portrait in the background Simon
wants to be the kind of feared and
respected leader that people would frame
on their walls he also mentions a title
this episode in the scene referring to
Rick and his people and they are real
go-getters and again by that he means
they proven that they can provide for
them without any real trouble but what
he doesn't realize is that many of them
are go-getters just in a very different
sense this whole episode tells us that
people like Maggie Sasha Karl and Enid
are all go-getters that take matters
into their own hands even when that
might not be exactly what the Savior's
wanted or intended like for example the
Savior's wanted to be able to clear all
the walkers as an active service for the
hilltop just like negan did for Rick
last episode but Maggie's go get her
attitude prevented them from being able
to do that and that same attitude for
Maggie reaches its peak when she punches
Gregory which is an awesome moment taken
directly from the comics and then she
delivers this powerful speech this is
our home now so you'll learn to start to
call me by my name
not Marcia not dear
Maggie Maggie Rhea now it's a pretty big
deal that Maggie is keeping Glenn's last
name which I don't think we hear too
often in the show
this shows that Maggie's identity going
forward will be forever linked with
Glenn's memory and that her actions will
be in Glenn's name just like the
Savior's actions or in negan's name I'll
come back to this thought but for now
let's jump back to Carl and Enid this
episode last time Carl and Enid wandered
off outside Alexandria together they
argued whether embracing their childhood
was a waste of time and this episode
completes that conversation these shots
have Enid and Carl roller skating
blissfully in the zombie apocalypse
they're just really sweet and touching
and a little surreal it has this feeling
of the last day of summer like they're
saying goodbye to their childhoods like
it kind of reminds me of that famous
shot from one of the final episodes of
Mad Men with Peggy Olson dreamily
rollerskating around the office as they
pack things up and leave like this all
felt so sweet there should have been
some kind of music to celebrate this no
no not that not that music anyway this
adorable rollerskating leads to them
holding hands and then kissing whoa they
are way too young for that I'm saving my
first kiss for marriage it's gonna be so
hot now anyway this is all meant to show
they're coming of age their childhood is
officially ending and now with these
hormonal romantic sparks they're
becoming official adults and now they
feel the same grief and do the same
blindly reckless boasts that adults
sometimes do now moving on when Maggie
finds Enid at Glen's grave and she sees
in its green balloons that gives Maggie
the sense of relief that Jesus said the
color green would earlier now she's
actually come to return Herschel's watch
to Glenn's grave but now she realized
that she doesn't need these physical
tokens to remember him by because she
shares Glen's memory with Enid now I
love how the next scene reveals that
Enid tie those balloons to the wrong
grave which is hilarious because I was
imagining Sasha just like charging up
the Gregory like burst you steal the
watch from Glenn's grave then you throw
a party on Abraham's plate you son of a
[ __ ] now Maggie proves that she
understands what Jesus said about
keeping the memory of our dead loved
ones and ourselves not in physical
objects echoing what he said earlier we
don't need anything
we have us but this scene ending with
these three women praying again reminds
me of that biblical reference I
discussed earlier but from a purely
historical perspective Jesus Christ was
a martyr who was crucified whose message
of love and community inspired a
movement starting with the mourners who
first preached that narrative
similarly Glenn I think will live on in
the walking dead as a martyr with Maggie
and the others doing acts in his name
but Wow Maggie
Enid may have found this place of
acceptance sasha hasn't we've seen how
colors are important this episode with
blue inspiring strength and green
inspiring release and now check out the
colors that are behind Sasha bright red
red is the color of passion sasha sent
Jesus to go find the Savior's compound
and she doesn't want Maggie to know so
my guess is she plans to be a go-getter
to attack them and she doesn't want
Maggie to join her or to try to stop her
sasha is still very much driven by
revenge and anger let's talk about these
closing images so as Maggie's prayer end
and we see the Savior's leave we hear
this foreboding sound of Sasha
sharpening her knife this is her version
of letting go of Abraham she's letting
the cigar burn just like the hilltoppers
burn their bodies and letting go of this
physical token but in doing so she's
embracing the devilish go-getter spirit
that Abraham championed
she's preparing to go to an extreme
Jesus and Karl proved to be the same
kind of reckless go-getters
so Jesus not only hops in the back of
the Savior's truck He pours out a bottle
of scotch that Simon lifted off Gregory
so why does he do this my guess is he's
hoping it will cause an argument between
the Savior's over who will drink it and
then he could use that distraction to
attack or maybe escape but we also get
this reveal of Karl in the truck - and
that sets up a storyline that is taken
directly from the comics
with Karl hiding in the back of the
truck on the way to the sanctuary and
the title of episode 7 which is two
episodes from now has been revealed as
sing me a song
now those of you who read the comics
might remember what this is a reference
to and it's looking like Carl's Ark the
season is about to get a lot more
interesting because Karl just like
Maggie Sasha
Enid Jesus and others they don't want to
be obedient weaklings who cower before
the saviors they want to go on the
offensive take initiative and be true
go-getters ok a few lingering questions
one do you think Simon actually knew
about the hilltops deal with Rick
so Gregory was working really hard to
play dumb without the satellite outposts
everyone died in there
Simon seemed to buy
then again if not Gregory how else would
Rick's people have known where the
satellite post was but now they figure
that Rick is under their control anyway
so they'll need to rock the boat and
replace Gregory who's still cowardly and
loyal to them and to where do you think
Rick and Michonne are going so Rick said
that he and Aaron were headed north to
scavenge for more stuff for negan but
Michonne was less clear
so my blind guess is that Rick and Aaron
could be on a collision course for the
kingdom while Michonne might be headed
towards the sanctuary or maybe she'll
run into Heath and Tara who are
obviously my favorite characters and I
cannot wait to catch up with them next
episode then again to be honest
based on these shots of Walker's covered
in sand plus the boat and a lot of
Masterson's new title slide Plus this
footage of next week's episode which I
don't want to show too much up because
it could be a spoiler this show might be
bringing in a whole new community that's
really only been mentioned briefly in
the comics so stay tuned next week's
episode could be very interesting okay
thanks for watching and let me know what
you think in the comments and check out
our breakdowns of the past Walking Dead
episodes including episodes one through
four of this season and please hit like
and subscribe to new rockstars and share
this video with all your friends you can
also contribute to us on patreon and
thanks so much to all of our current
donors you guys are the best for the
rest of you if you aren't currently a
patron we'd love your support you can
hit me up on Twitter at EA boss with any
questions or thoughts that you had about
The Walking Dead or you can follow new
rock stars on Twitter at new rock stars
alright thanks for watching bye
[Music]
you